martin landry et épidémiologiste à
l'université d'oxford et directeur du
big data institute c'est notre rubrique
vu de l'extérieur ce soir bonsoir martin
landry merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france ou d'abord un petit point
sur l'essai discovery dont on attend
beaucoup
où en est-on concrètement nous venons
d'entendre que l'essai discovery
semblait être enlisée je l'entends de
vous mais également la métropole source
il faut comprendre que cet essai mais
qu'un les séparent mais beaucoup de
grands essais cliniques qui vise à
essayer de comprendre quels traitements
fonctionnent pour lutter contre le coc
vides il y en a beaucoup d'autres très
similaires dans le monde par exemple
l'un d'entre eux le pc solidarity menée
par l'om s est laissée recovery menée au
royaume uni pourquoi est ce si compliqué
d'avoir des résultats pourquoi ça patine
selon vous question de la lenteur ou
plutôt de des problèmes pour recruter
des patients avec l'essai discovery
c'est une question qu'il faudrait poser
aux personnes qui mènent le laisser au
royaume uni le laisser recovery est très
semblable et étudie cinq médicaments
pour les patients admis à l'hôpital avec
le co vie 19
nous avons mis en place était une très
rapidement
la première description scientifique
assez fait neuf jours avant le premier
premier recrutement du premier patient
dans deux semaines laissé été mise en
place et nous avons plus de 9500
patients à ce jour donc il est possible
de mener des essais cliniques
relativement simple et une très large
qui mèneront à des réponses mais en même
temps il y avait une urgence en
évidemment due à cette crise du
coronavirus beaucoup dont emmanuel
macron en tête se montrent optimistes
attendent beaucoup tout de même de cet
essai discovery est ce que c'est votre
cas aussi vous pensez que ça va produire
des résultats tangibles
chaque chaque faits supplémentaires est
très important et c'est plus important
que c'est plus en tout cas efficace que
de donner des médicaments sans savoir
s'il fonctionne ou pas effectivement les
essais sont cruciaux mais je dirais que
vous avez raison lorsque le koffi 19 a
frappé paris ou londres mi mars
c'était un fardeau extraordinaire entrée
libre pour les services de santé les
médecins et également les patients qui
se porte mal qui sont très inquiets pour
leur santé et qui se sentent seules à
cause de la distanciation est pour le
mieux je pense que l'un des secrets que
nous avons trouvé aura lui c'est que les
essais doivent être simples à mettre en
place pour les docteurs pour les
infirmiers et pour les patients il faut
éliminer toutes les barrières qui
empêchent de prendre part à ces essais
ils sont que les essais cliniques qui
nous permettent de différencier les
médicaments prometteurs plein d'espoir
et les médicaments qui fonctionne
concrètement alors parmi les médicaments
dont on a en tout cas beaucoup parlé ici
en france il ya l'hydroxyde chloroquine
a prôné par le professeur à août à
marseille
vous en tant que professionnel quels
sont les retours que vous en avez
précisément sur ce médicament dans le
cadre de l'essai discovery
cela fait des décennies qu'on utilise
hydroxyque leur queen par exemple pour
lutter contre la malaria
mais il n'y a pas de preuve qu'elle est
efficace face aux compétitions à fond et
il n'ya pas non plus de preuve qu'elle
ne fonctionne pas il ya beaucoup de
spéculations et pas de fête
et pourtant les patients ont besoin de
faits concrets de preuves
les docteurs les patients et ils ne les
obtient que grâce à ces essais qui sont
donc des essais randomisés à grande
échelle sur ce médicament et l'analyse
des résultats sur les patients c'est
vraiment le crucial afin de compenser le
truc sic le au queen est un traitement
efficace inefficaces ou même un
traitement dangereux on peut tous
spéculer nous n'avons pas besoin de
spéculations ont besoin de connaissances
à votre avis l'europe a été unie dans ce
combat contre le coc vide 19s qu'on
communique acs qui l'y a suffisamment de
cohésion entre les différents pays
je pense que beaucoup d'efforts pour de
la cohésion de la collaboration
c'était vraiment exceptionnel de cette
crise la faculté des gens de travailler
ensemble lors qu'il n'avait jamais fait
auparavant
cela est vraiment très bon signe et
mettant chacun d'eux
les problèmes sont différents et même au
sein des pays
les situations sont très différentes à
paris ce n'est pas une chose qu'à
bordeaux et à londres la situation est
différente que par exemple un lead ou à
manchester ou birmingham
chaque ville a ses spécificités on peut
effectivement mettre en place une
coordination au niveau national et
international
mais les solutions doivent se trouver
sur le terrain dans les hôpitaux
individuelle et auprès des deux auteurs
des infirmiers et des patients si on ne
les appliquent pas si on ne facilite pas
la tâche à ces personnes qui prennent
vraiment en charge le fardeau alors dû à
des problèmes
merci beaucoup martine l'on est d'avoir
été avec nous je rappelle que vous êtes
épidémiologiste à l'université d'oxford
directeur du big data institute merci
d'avoir été avec nous